Calgary changing Greer dumps the puck in
posil on it with a pass to cadri shoots
Put It Wide posil he shoots turned away by
soken and he's able to gather in the rebound
and hang on Islanders back on the attack but
Hanan picks the pocket of walstrom and now
it's posil with a been a r posil right in SC
a beauty by b m and it's one of the [Music]
calary all over it but first of all the Flames
have been doing this all game long breaking the
cycle there they break it Zary with a B
little chip this Best Line a little play
off the boards and then Poss L what ball oh
my I mean he outweighs soken and then throws
it right up high he's got a Rolling Puck which
helps him and he just lifts him right over the
goalie and a beautiful Play What a pass by cadri
to use the boards pelic with the clear see Simone
Under Pressure hter there bouncing Puck comes
free here's a shot the SC bashing Fires at home
and ties it up at one as Hudson fashion gets his
first of the season the boards I believe y on a
change so he's just going to come won right in
from the Ben and there is the play that works
in the half boards and the Flames really never
get sorted out defensively after the giveaway on
the boards here Sharon goich and D Simone right
there and there comes bashing Off the Bench and
the puck ends up on a stick pretty good shot as
he changes the angle on markstrom play been much
better of the special teams they've scored four
in the last two games on the man Advantage they
go to work here doson fakes passing one timer
patch and they score on the rebound Paul Mary
puts it in came right back out but hit the
back of the net it is a power play goal and
Kyle Palmer gives the Islanders their first
lead well first of all you win the draw and
he's really the Catalyst because you're worried
about his shot to begin with and so he'll they'll
get it back to him eventually here it comes
and then he'll f shot so we're be sick he's
going to shoot and he sets up the one timer and
then Paul Mar who's one of the better players in
the game at picking up Pucks in the crease area
and he just picks up the rebound off the pad of
markstrom p over to doson here's a
giveaway the score Anderson gives
the puck right to Matthew barzel
who fires at home makes it 3-1
Islanders
it's a really tough play for a goalie because
it all of a sudden just arrives and you're not
even set the Islanders win it it's four on four
Anderson's in front and he's just trying to tip
it through his Center Iceman but he ends up
throwing it right on the tape of barzel and
frankly I'm not quite sure what he was thinking
there I mean that's just a a brain cramp what
else can you say and it goes right in and third
and four for the Islanders they were in Vancouver
on Wednesday and Seattle on Thursday here's
Holstrom cutting in Pat sh barkstrom checked
and wal Muses the puck back outside the zone that
ahead quickly back to the line HTO in front great
save soken what a tip by hubero on the setup by
backlin and sokin Best Stop of the night for him
back comes bin hubo hits d c line let's go colan
puts it in and it's a one go [Music] [Applause]
game the cles given it away back as I mentioned
likes driving the middle this's a great play by
the by the Simone as he just Waits Waits
Waits draws everybody towards him colan
goes to that for the stick down and we
got a 3-2 hockey game beautiful goal
cadri xeri comes away with a puck weager sets up
for the onetime scores hit something
in front let a g off and iser [Music]
TI so weager picks up his second goal in as
many games in fourth on the season that's
eight goals by the Flames Blue Line in eight
games Islanders look to answer back great save
Mar off New York right back on top another sa
rebound score Islanders answer back on a goal
by Brock Nelson seconds later and New York back
on top 43 car off here throws the puck around
the board youo can't get it out and now it's
fire drill there's some running around going
on and the puck just arrives on the stick after
the shot does not get through but Nelson finds
some daylight and sneaks in behind the def right
off the draw pass across to pull off with a shot
that changed Direction two6 rebound Puck loose
cry able to fight it off H with a good look on
a set up by bzel after a turnover by the Flames
deep in their own end another chance Mar with the
save and the rebounds fire down the ice Adam pelic
Banks it to lead slows it down pass in front and
stopped by marstrom as that chance by walstrom
might have caught the post two the second to see
if the puck was in or not there's Hanah him down
the wing with a shot here's duet now on the far
side T of one timer got it into the legs of mapani
and now it's cleared up by the Islanders who have
been close to making it 53 on multiple occasions
here in the last few minutes pass back to Hanan
shoots the SC H something on the way by shering
gois with the tip and we're all T [Music] up and
Lyle's been quiet all game long but he does what
he does best here works the play on the fors finds
the open man and Hanan who's really coming
on offensively here lets it rip and I think
that went straight in on sokin on the short side
we'll have another look at it here it's Sharon
govic cabry pocket pick barcel falling up the pil
for the win trying to go five rebound play of f
can't do it back back on the attack backl makes a
move throws it across tipped in front hubo stopped
by shok got the arm on that one Jor Sharon gich
scored the equalizer it's four for seven in his
shootout career make it five for eight what a
beautiful move wow little delay Waits oh boy
that's pretty move one for one this season in the
shootout comes in with speed on marra slows down
scores Nice Shot Horvat to go that speed now
what he does he stops that freezes the goenda
shot that was to finish it up on marrom barzel
marstrom with the save a bit of relief there
for markstrom as barzel has been terrific and
he's such a natural goal scorer Conor Z starts
round for the shootout Zer stayed by soken
right patch stop there for the Islanders go
Cher there's another crafty player
we've watched that in moments ago
when he went in on a l and Westrom and
walstrom deaker we'll see walstrom has
a chance to win it now Oliver walstrom on
markstrom scores posted in and walstrom
ends a seven game winless skit for the
Islanders and round four the shootout